what what is that is that a bomb
what is that it's beeping put it down
bucky it's beeping
that was the commodore bead that's
another camoya bead
white wolf still at it someone's leaving
breadcrumbs for you dude
and then he's wondering when you're
gonna show up there oh
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars the
falcon in the winter soldier episode 3
episode titled power broker teams up sam
and bucky with
dance off to save the universe contender
baron zemo
and sharon carter
hopping from germany the bad before to
the baltic with a dash of wakanda in
there
yep uh this storm allah cameo is
actually way bigger than just mere
vengeance for t'chaka i'm telling you
i'm telling you
and sharon carter what's going on with
her uh we'll we'll talk about that
that's
uh a question for inside marvel new rock
stars after show for the winter
soldier i'm eric boss here with mt
what's going on after this episode oh
man this episode was
pretty good i was i've been missing
sharon carter for so long so it's so
great to see her
kick ass like she really messed up some
dudes
and uh she's here for it the this
episode felt like a john wick
kind of fever dream in a way going to
match report with you know those bounty
alerts on their phones sharon carter
throwing knives through people's arms
it felt like uh they took characters
that we knew from civil war
and then just said ah what if they were
this instead
right what if they were john wick flavor
let's let's find out oh
yeah a lot of fun action um some very
confusing characterization at times that
we have questions about
apparently german prisons have never had
a prison riot before because it was
way too easy for a super villain to
escape that prison
i mean maybe they were just well-behaved
prisoners up until that point and then
they're just like we've never had a riot
before how do we handle this
chest day we're really having a fight on
chess day guys i thought we had a deal
uh well okay in this after show we're
gonna answer your biggest
wtfs which to us of course stands for
what the
so in this episode episode three bucky
helps zemo break out of this prison at
first it seems hypothetically but just
kidding it's uh
aesthetically which i guess means far
too
easily and way too fast really just
writer's saying we just need him out of
prison okay don't question it
yeah and then apparently this whole
gritty sokovian militant version of zemo
that we saw in civil war
also had a ton of few money he was a
baron
a bunch of cars he loves classic cars
the chemistry among this trio was really
fun to watch
uh they take this private jet to
madrapore where they team up with sharon
carter who is a
faithful government agent and captain
america winter soldier and civil war
turned
insane john wick universe character
yeah who's now like an art uh dealer um
sure and they uh all together tracked
down
through a bunch of like uh deals being
made to this guy dr nagel
which is an interesting name from the
comics he was part of project rebirth
the whole isaiah bradley
program uh in this show he's the
scientist who bounced from hydra to the
cia to the power broker and
ended up replicating 20 doses of super
soldier serum
that were sent stolen by the flag
smashers who i guess plan to give it to
kids come on kids i mean yeah that's the
last group of people i would give
any sort of power to but right maybe not
uh and then in the final scene bucky uh
follows a trail of komoyo beads 2
adorama lager this is ao wakanda
we got some wakanda representatives what
kind of drums there too
so cool i missed it i didn't know how
much i missed that music until it
happened like oh my god it's been so
long since black panther
i know so we're gonna talk about this
black panther crosstalk we're gonna talk
about zemo we're gonna talk about sharon
carter
and why she's probably not the power
broker herself i know some of you are
saying she must be the power broker no
no
but she is weird as hell on the show so
we're gonna talk about why that's
sketchy
yeah oh and real quick i am wearing our
latest
obsession shirt this is anarchy
assembled you can get these at new
yorksourcemerch.com if you do
you'll unlock an additional option to
write in a custom shout out that will
appear at the bottom of these inside
marvel after shows
for example we got jeff jackson famous
jeff
jackson i love that reference
yeah oh man uh he says don't trust the
therapist
yeah trust therapists in general we all
do better with the baby therapy therapy
is great if you need therapy
go to therapy but you know therapy i do
understand what they're saying with
don't trust a therapist because like the
the camera angles on episode one were
kind of weird but we'll stop
and then oliver holmes says i really
hope that arnhem zola will come into the
show
hey oliver you and us right
together on that welcome to zola train
let's go
any way that we can try to work zola
into this we will
um and then uh sabrina baskerville says
little not sexist uh yeah
clearly clearly he was very clear with
that
i think yeah he boldly declared himself
as such
i love it honestly i would love if kevin
feige just made him the first time like
yes
oh he would be perfect for the role so
good
all right mt what's her first what the
falcon well i'm glad you asked eric
because the first what the falcon of the
day
is what the is the dora melange
eo doing here in this program
yeah uh okay so let's talk about this
ending scene ao this uh
actresses florets florence casumba she
was really second in command of
wakanda's door milaje royal guard she
served right underneath okoye
and she was actually the first member of
the dora milaje we met appearing in
captain america what uh civil war
and uh she was t'challa's bodyguard and
she later
reappeared in black panther and avengers
infinity war actually we weren't sure if
she was still alive
because last time we saw her she was
facing off with corvus glaive to protect
shuri
and shuri was racing to detach the mind
stone from vision
so our buddy vision is getting
reconnected with this i love it
um this episode reminded us of course
that zemo was the actual man responsible
for king
chaka's death and the wakandas are just
not gonna let that go so now it seems
like ao is just
there to bring zemo to justice sure sure
it makes sense but
wakanda crossing over into the storyline
broadens the map of the series even
further it means
bucky's past as the white wolf is going
to be even more important at this show
because at the same time on the show
until you've noticed this the history of
erskine's super soldier serum is really
at the heart of it
yeah and in this episode we talked about
its origins with red skull and how
erskine was originally working with red
skull
and then it went to cap and it bulked
him up and then
hydra tried to recreate it for their
winter soldier program and then we know
it went to isaiah bradley
uh and then dr nagle and the cia the
cia's involved in this and then
after the snap happened he ended up on
the other side of that
joining the power broker and then that's
where the flag smashers stole it but
throughout all this history there's
always been one missing piece to it
uh we're always wondering what made
erskine's
serum different when he gave it to cap
versus when he gave it a red skull
what was that missing ingredient um
probably barbecue sauce honestly pretty
much yeah
yeah uh yeah a sriracha or a bit of
tapatio
you just like we just throw something in
there some parsley just stood some trial
and error
but yeah that's a very good point
because like we just don't know
what made um that steve rogers formula
so
potent so perfect so perfect and i think
we might have a big clue here based on
the themes of this series and the show
now extending its roots to wakanda that
erskine might have derived a component
of this serum
from the wakandan heart-shaped herb
now that has been brought up in mcu
theories before i think we've talked
about on this channel
uh plenty of times but that would be the
one missing ingredient
and it would stay true to this whole
idea of captain america's legacy
using a shield made of vibranium
presumably taken from mount bashang or
somewhere in wakanda
all vibranium in the world is like
considered to be property of the
wakandan people
and now in this case he could be
empowered by another resource
that you could argue is appropriated
colonized from that soil
so now uh ao could be the key to that
missing
link do you think i'm on anything here
empty i
really really like that because um
like the mcu is a very science heavy um
and logic heavy universe so to have to
bring it back to like all right so irk
sign
possibly went to wakanda or possibly
just found this heart-shaped herb
and and used the science behind the herb
to develop the formula i would
love that to just wheel around because
then it would explain
black panther's physiology when he had
it
and also killmonger when he took the
black herb as well
so i'm the heart shaper as well so like
i really
really love that theory well and then
nagel says in this episode he's like i
refine the process no more like a muscle
growth or anything like that
it's uh just um it's subtle yeah and
that's what it is in black panther it's
just
the purest version of it it just
enhances their agility their strength
their speed
when they take it in and um and when
erskine talks about what his cocktail
was made of it
he also talked about steroids to
simulate stimulate growth and the
spider rays or all these other things on
top of it but like basically it's the
difference between ecstasy and mdma you
know it's
you know yeah superior version and it's
not the same thing
but it makes you feel the same you can
just like brule
all night with that stuff dude i love
that they went to the club in this
episode i was just dying
it's like hey we need some time to kill
let's take uh zebo to the club which
is dancing like just really lame
they gave us just enough time to make a
gift out of it
thank you thank you editor of this video
thank you to our
editors by the way i i ended up working
in a shout out to our editors there
because i don't thank them enough
john and sean they are wonderful
everybody that does work on the show
like magicians
all of you we love you thank you yeah
off-screen staff
uh brandon barrick and zach huddleston
all you guys
uh but now that we have ao in the show i
didn't think we would see a black
panther reference this soon
do you think we'll get any reference to
t'challa or what his status
is see that's the first thing i thought
of when i saw ao i was like are we gonna
get an
update like what's gonna go on um i i
hope so i think that
uh the next episode we're gonna find out
what exactly or get a hint at
um what's going on with t'challa because
i honestly do think that kevin feige
is waiting for um like a theatrical
release
where more eyes will be on it to
announce you know hey what's happening
with cap first of all and
b um what is going to go on with um
obviously
with chadwick bozeman's death and the
character of t'challa
so i i do think we're gonna we're gonna
get some sort of hint towards uh
the fate of uh t'challa in the next yeah
i i think they'll probably leave the
door open in a lot of ways because
a lot of this was written and shot
before chadwick passed away
um and they did do some reshoots that
were after that
but i have to imagine this was all
before yeah or at least it was
her role in the show was planned before
but it is interesting that ao
is kind of our globe trotting spy now
and normally she as the dora milane has
to kind of protect the
the royal the moderator for the country
so does her
and they do the dorm elijah do often
jump around the world as we saw in
um in the black panther movie she
flanked him at the u.n normally it's
like
with the monarch they usually go out on
their own
um but do you think this could mean like
maybe if if uh ao is head of this royal
guard
could okoye have stepped up as a new
black panther that'd be an interesting
interesting
i would love to see okoye as a as the
new black panther
um i i personally would like i want to
see um
um nadia i believe was uh black
panther's love interest oh yeah yeah um
become the black next black panther um
but akoya would be
an excellent um uh step up
yeah what i kind of want is like uh the
black panther
and the throne of wakanda don't have to
be the same
it'd be great if shuri could be the
ruler of wakanda and then okoye could be
the black panther figure or that mbaku
could play one of these roles because
he's obviously a great leader and a
great partner
would be a great choice for black
panther he's he's got the charisma he's
got the
he's got the guns um he would be he
would be fantastic but
yes i do like the idea of shuri being a
ruler but
also like a ruler slash woman in the
chair
for okoya because shuri's like super
smart obviously
so it'd be a nice little like you know
i'm a ruler but i'm also you're you're
tech
person and like you're the one kicking
ass so like i do like that idea
i'm just thinking like if you're malcolm
spellman and you want to bring in a
wakandan royal guard in this show like
his end goal
i think is to try to uh expose like the
real history
of uh the captain america legacy and
like in the same way that it was
denied that dream was deferred for
isaiah
like maybe that dream was originally
his birthright if you make it something
that was rooted in wakanda
so i'd love to see them go in that
direction i don't think it would be that
controversial because we already know
that vibranium shield came from wakanda
you know yeah
i think that'd be great i i imagine if
they like secretly make
like you know isaiah bradley have
wakandan origins that would be
super dope it's like hey we had the
first
black captain america was actually
wakandan so this is a content legacy
uh yeah yeah uh but i think uh yeah so
we'll see what comes out of that i think
it's really cool that
uh i thought just references to wakanda
and the white wolf were just kind of
like
we're referencing other things that
happened before but for them to actually
bring in the character from that corner
of the universe is really cool i'm
very excited like when it when uh when
bucky started picking up those beads i
was like
no it could not be no
but they did it i was like oh
anyway
yeah um so we're going to talk more
about sharon carter the power broker
zemo all these other questions first we
want to thank some people who helped us
make this episode this
episode is sponsored by betterhelp so is
there something interfering with your
happiness
or is preventing you from achieving your
goals well better help
assesses your needs and matches you with
your own licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating with them in under 48
hours
now this is not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's just professional
counseling done
securely online uh now this service is
available for clients worldwide you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room with
you know as you might with traditional
therapy and better help is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed and it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today just visit their
website and read their testimonials
visit betterhelp.com marvel that's
betterhelp.com
marvel and join the over 1 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional special offer for inside
marvel listeners you can get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
marvel uh we also want to thank our
friends at magic spoon for sponsoring us
so lots of us are trying to eat better
but healthy breakfast doesn't have to be
boring
magic spoon has the amazing flavors you
love but without all the bad stuff
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein and only four net grams of carbs
in each serving
only 140 calories a serving it's keto
friendly gluten free gluten-free
grain-free soy-free low-carb and gmo
free
get yourself a variety pack of the four
flavors cocoa fruity frosted and peanut
butter
get creative and mix the cocoa and
peanut butter for a peanut butter cup
go to magicspoon.com marvel to grab a
variety pack and try it today
and be sure to use our promo code marvel
at check out to save five dollars off
your order
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked remember get your next delicious
bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com
marvel and use the code marvel to save
five dollars off thank you to magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode
all right mt back to our what the
falcons i want to know from you who the
falcon is the power broker
he comes up so much this episode yes um
so apparently power broker is a crime
lord who lives
in madrid this new city that we have uh
gone to in episode three of falcon the
winner soldier now it seems like he has
bad blood with
zemo baron zemo apparently this rich
zemo
um and from a deleted scene in civil war
in which zemo gassed an arms dealer at
an
auction yeah do you think that could
have been it right like there was that
moment where
zemo just kind of made enemies with a
lot of high-powered uh
crime figures around the world these
international black market dealers
like that could have been the moment
where he's like you killed him yeah i
mean like
yeah i i mean zemo's just like a dick in
general
so like i'm not surprised that he has
like
a bad blood with this power broker guy
but i think that that could be a very
good
hint towards you know potentially uh
what happened in the past
but with with deleted scenes it's kind
of hard because like it's a canon is it
not canon i don't know
but yeah deleted scenes technically
aren't really canon but
yeah it shows intent yes it does show
that they were thinking about it at the
very least
um but the power broker as we see in
at the end credits of falcon winner
soldier that he's always watching so
like
does he have a surveillance or a spy
network could zola
be behind the john wick bounty app
though yeah because uh
empty that was a whole big thing this um
uh selby person got shot and literally
like
20 seconds later word got out on this
app
like this is a bounty this is who they
are it seems like there's some kind of
sophisticated technology
behind that so either the power broker
had eyes on that scene maybe through
sharon carter
uh and then they they had that app uh
ready to go
and this is just something that happens
in this world kind of john wick's style
they all
automatically all get notified um
but yeah i thought that was interesting
uh
for zola to be behind it oh yeah i hope
i pray
is the technology man and it makes sense
like this power broker he's
fast like he'd be texting carly carly
mad fast and he's always watching so
like
it would make sense for zola to be um
just behind all of this that reveal
empty would be so
wild you know like i will finally jump
it would be some wizard of oz
they're like are you ready to meet the
power broker and it's just a green
face on a giant screen
i would love i would literally be so
hyped so
hype i mean empty and i just did a video
this week oh i
we were both on it mt did all the the
leg work and like telling us
this history of uh of the power broker
in the comics
go watch that video mt does such a good
job in that video uh first time in the
blue dungeon
it's it's weirdly cold in here right yes
it's cold
but i'm glad that philip feeds us
regularly he's a very nice man
it's just uh a bag of rice
not cooked or anything just drink it's
just right the raw rice he gives us one
bag of rice a day we share it
and you have to finish it there's not a
grain he'll look around for the grain
yes
you will float around the blue void for
the any grain if you leave a grain
there's no rice tomorrow
right um yeah but in that video we were
kind of going into some theories of who
we think this power broker figure could
be because we knew obviously this show
is it's setting it up to be something
big
mt had this cool theory about how uh
white vision from one division could be
connected to that
i after this episode mt i'm feeling
pretty good about this mandarin ten
rings theory
yeah yeah like the fact that he's a
crime lord they use this kind of place
as like a pirate colony pretty much
like how many criminal warlords are
there in this universe probably a lot
but the one that they're setting up
in a title this year is going to be the
mandarin
yeah i would not be surprised if the
shows up at some point or is directly
referenced in this episode because the
mandarin
as we saw in the all hail the king short
he's he's not messing around he's
sort of like he's sort of watching
people like he's watching trevor in
prison
and he's got like agents all over the
place right yeah there
there was like and feige even said this
at the comic con panel the dude in iron
man 2 who gives ivan vancouver his like
uh
his new identity paperwork that dude was
in the ten rings
the guy an ant-man who was touring the
pym facility to try to get the yellow
jacket tech he had a 10 rings tattoo
um that was clear in his last angry
face looking shot before he got punched
and knocked out
so like these guys are everywhere and
like and what i like about the mandarin
theory is that he is uh
mandarin's not exactly hiding you know
he's hiding in madrid but he's not
uh um a kaiser soze figure that much
whereas
if it were someone like thaddeus ross
thaddeus ross is a government official
in the u.s government i don't think he'd
be able to pull off like
uh a shadowy side figure whose name was
the power broker who had graffiti
everywhere
yeah you know declaring his existence
like if anything he would not have
another alias he would and
he wouldn't be like proud about it yeah
sneaky sneaky this is someone who likes
to flaunt it a bit and the mandarin is
someone who likes to fly
yeah i i honestly i i sort of hope
that's the mandarin because it would be
perfect set up for
shang chi and the mandarin he's a he's
not someone to be trifled with he will
mess you up and people are very much
afraid of this man
so it would it would be really cool for
um
at least a player at the very least a
player in the series
that is teased for shanxi in the future
yeah
we'll see the third with the falcon for
today is
what the falcon is sharing carter's real
agenda eric yeah that is a good question
a lot of people are saying sharon
carter's a power broker no no i don't
think sharon carter is
the power broker just because she the
power broker sounds like someone who for
decades has kind of built up this empire
sharon only as of 2016 did
uh start to have to resort to flee too
and i don't think she would have the
time to build up i think she is an arms
dealer
i think her character's super weird now
i like seeing her fight
that she would be this like kind of arms
dealer who would weirdly laugh off stuff
and then in the next second complain how
she can't call her dad anymore
like and then uh the weird thing is at
the end of the episode she gets
in the back of this car and she goes
we've got a big problem actually a
couple of them i'll tell you in the car
let's go and then she has a driver
like that was interesting so i'm
thinking her couple of problems
was one that dr nagel is dead
um i think she might be working for the
power broker
and power broker needed nagel to and
that was new information for her for
sure
um and that that he had died and then uh
secondly i think the problem is is that
uh people
know like sharon wasn't in that lab at
the time
um for most of it she was doing all the
leg work to
you know defend it outside good lord
but i think she feels threatened now
that zemo is out that um
bucky and sam know this information and
that this poses a problem to the power
broker
yes um it would be very interesting to
see
um sharon carter working for the power
broker potentially because like she
is kind of just asked out luck she just
got kicked out of america essentially
and she's just trying to make her ends
meet so it would
make sense for her in this position to
be
sort of workish for the power broker but
at the same time
i just we just don't really know exactly
what
exactly what she's doing so i'm very
interested but we'll see yeah she might
have been
um like seduced and recruited by the ten
rings
you know like i could see her getting
approached in major poor in a bar
saying like hey so your government
abandoned you right
thaddeus ross uh labeled you an enemy of
the state
you have to come here now but you have
uh you have some interesting skills how
would you like to work in security for
us and because she's such a badass
now she's like one of the big assassins
in magipur working underneath
the power broker and like she was the
sniper in that window she threw a knife
in some guy's arm she used a guy as a
human shield she's basically john wick
now like
yeah that's interesting i don't know if
she had that
i mean she was a badass shield agent
before but now she's like vicious
and that might have just been survival
skills but it's just
it's weird that steve would have
abandoned her over the
course of two years i just assumed
between winter soldier
or between civil war and infinity war
that like even though sharon carter
wasn't with the three of them
uh attracting like vision and wanda
through europe i just assumed that like
she was being taken care of yeah like
she was you know she wouldn't have
needed to become this crazy arts dealer
in magipor
she could have like gotten by just you
know through her old spy contacts or
something
yeah she could have easily helped yes
help steve in infinity war you know just
been on his team because
why not they're all on the run let's be
on the run together you know
exactly yeah why couldn't she help them
um she's like let me
go on they're like oh there's only room
for three people in this car there's a
fourth seat but it's like no no sam
likes to put his seat way back he
doesn't like to move it
right but i can crouch no sorry bye
so we just took out the room sorry yeah
now
do you think empty that sharon carter
was alive during the blip
because did i miss something there um
like maybe that's how
she spent all this time building things
but i would i would assume
that sharon carter was alive during the
blip okay um
because she she does seem to have been
entrenched in magipore for a while so
i would guess five years um would be
enough to turn this woman into a
just a killing ruthless uh madrapore
machine
magikarp murder machine um to keep the
alliteration up
i think five years is enough time for
her to become like a high-ranking
security yeah um
worker for the power brokers network
work but not to take over
like an entire criminal enterprise
enterprise where people are saying power
brokers watching they're referring to
sharon carter
who's walking around in the street
taking her hood off
like doesn't add up for sure yeah it
does yeah i don't i don't think that
cheering card is a power broker at all
i'll just say if they reveal that it's
gonna be real lame and it's gonna be
another like great
yeah yeah it would be sort of like uh
like you know like the
mandarin thing in iron man 3 right right
just be like come on be like you
couldn't just make a new character that
would be nice
just a new character would be cool all
right our next what the falcon mt
is uh what do you think is next for the
super soldier serum we know the flag
smashers want to give it to these kids
um but did it look like they had these
close-ups of the vials
in nagel's lab do you think anybody
snatched any of those vials
i think that those vaccines maybe in
episode 2
could have contained some vials maybe
like yeah that was being transported
which is why the power broker cares so
much about you know his stuff being
taken because like it feels back
just vaccines i'm sure the power broker
be like all right they
they mess with me but you know it won't
be the end of the world but
since the power broker cares so much
about this cargo
i would not be surprised if carly's
stole a couple of x uh
no for sure yeah oh no i think that's
that's totally the implication i think
the idea was those vaccines contained
less concentrated doses of it and they
were going to disperse it
to people they considered worthy of it
but i'm talking about in the lab right
as it was exploding and burning down
they had close-up of those vials i'm
thinking
did zemo grab one did bucky or sam grab
one
that is very interesting i wouldn't be i
wouldn't put a pazzimo to grab one for
himself
because you know he's freshly out of
prison and he's like you know what i'm
gonna cause some some mayhem
but at the same time zemo is very
against super soldiers and
and superpowers so you know but he he
might have taken one put in his pockets
like i don't know what we're gonna do
with this but i'm gonna
it's better to have this that did not
have this right it's the ultimate
hypocrisy
i would say maybe he could use it as
leverage or something to like
uh force the flag smashers to heal or
to you know uh get to john walker and
then like tempt him with it or something
like that and then
get a permanent um you know pardon or
something
like i'll hand you over this cocktail
but yeah at the end of the day he
he does hate the whole concept of super
soldiers but what i do think is going to
happen and it's something that i feel
like this episode is teasing
with john walker we see john walker
really just angry in this episode and
being
like a mega dick and but i feel like a
lot of that frustration comes from his
lack of power because people
don't find him and he i i feel that he
feels
that people don't find him intimidating
because he doesn't have the strength
of captain america and so i feel like
this
is setting up the seeds for i need power
i need power and then he's going to go
to the power broker or
um you know maybe come across one of
nagel's vials and
take it himself and then get juiced up
um
and then pretend like he wasn't juiced
up i don't know i yeah i think he might
already have
i think his anger in that moment was
about respect
like he's mad that people don't see him
as a replacement cap
and he still carries the shield he wears
a similar costume he has the same name
but people know they're they're not
afraid to spit in his face because they
don't respect him
but like i would also say if steve
rogers were doing what
john walker was doing he also would have
gotten a lugie to the face it's not that
he's not steve rogers
it's that he of a police we have this
whole opening
image of like the grc what a great thing
smash cut to
police van opens up on the shield like
this guy
he's raiding it he's like screaming at
people steve rogers didn't do that
you know yeah and like you know
obviously you know
captain america with john walker anyway
it's just a
symbol and right this guy who was
harboring the flag smashers was like yo
f symbols and you're a captain symbol so
like you know
[Laughter]
but yeah no yeah totally i
john walker he's trying to become he's
like you said in episode two
the best captain america that he can be
yeah so with him not being respected
he's just like
i'm not really captain america am i ah
this is so frustrating
yeah um but yeah no it's i do like what
the the direction that they're taking
john walker yeah
that he goes more crazy honestly oh me
too yeah um
now we talked about zemo a little bit
there what the falcon does zemo
know like do you think he's an ulterior
motive is he hiding something from sam
and bucky
what do you think oh yeah i think that
there's probably some some major
hydra secrets uh and stuff that he knows
about the super soldier
program that he's not telling sam and
bucky um and he's
100 using them and like when sam and
bucky started getting shot
um and like running away and you know
that shot that we see in the trailer
um i i thought that zemo just dipped i
thought he was gone
but he came back and with the mask on
and he was just
just tearing up and so what do you
think is the significance behind that
mask like there was a moment where he
lingered on the mask on the dashboard
there was a like trunks full of other
treasures in that garage like there were
golden guns there were knives there's
all this other gear
it seemed to be alluding that some other
super villainy passed
um with zemo he kind of felt like a
goofy bond villain didn't he this
episode
it sort of did and i sort of felt like
this might have been like maybe like a
family thing
or like or a family tradition where like
they're just like thieves or something
and like they wear that little ski mask
and do crimes
or it wore it's just something that he
used to wear back in his um back in the
day when he was
in um just i don't know just doing
evil stuff or like being in like a or i
don't know
i i do feel like it's something
connected to his past and he's
he's worn it a lot and something that he
usually takes into
uh altercations like that
yeah it's it's interesting because the
characterization the backstory we got of
him in civil war is that he was just
this uh sokovian militant he kind of led
a death squad
uh during these past conflicts of
sokovia but now he describes himself as
a royal
um and he's like a royal without a
country anymore
uh which just feels like a comp it feels
like you know they'll have like
prince william or prince harry do a
little bit they'll do a tour of service
in in the british armed forces uh it
just it's kind of like a
this is just a rite of passage they have
to learn the
the steps of what their military
units do um but like that
uh now it just doesn't sit well with me
it felt like there was a version of zemo
in civil war
that worked and it was fine and now the
show is like no we're gonna make him
more like his comic book version
but uh i didn't need zemo to be rich
i don't know yeah like i do like the
the want the zemo that we were sort of
getting teased of in in
civil war like with the like just i have
a family and i was just a victim of
terrible circumstances yeah
but like now that zemo's rich i'm just
like well now i kind of care
about your past a little bit less
because you were pretty well to do
um but at the same time you know it does
suck to lose a family so
right and it just felt like they made
him rich so that they could have a
private jet that sam and bucky could
travel around the world without having
to go through customs and stuff
yeah it did seem a little bit like a
plot
moving forward element that they were
just like all right we just he's rich
and he has a plane so we're going to mag
report
yeah um and there was like some kind of
raw rage with him in civil war that i
feel like is lost now don't get me wrong
i love what daniel bruhl is doing with
this he was a delight to watch this
episode
he was fantastic every time the camera
cut to him i was like
he's making a fun choice right my
favorite
it's just the plotting with the
character it's like if you're bringing
zemo back it seems like the writers of
the show don't really know exactly what
to do with zemo and didn't really
understand what zemo was in civil war
um not to say they have to i mean in
thor ragnarok taika with tt completely
took over that world
and made it his own and it was great but
really the world the tone changed but
the character stayed true
thor was just as bit as self-obsessed
and uh
took himself way too seriously as was
loki loki was still
a huge ego uh hulk was really maybe the
only one who changed because he actually
had
a personality now but it was justified
by
the nature of that world uh so really
it's just a world around them that
felt goofy and changed so we went along
with it it's different when you take a
character
and fundamentally things that were
important to them before
are no longer important bucky for
example like
he would not care that much about
hunting down the super soldier serum
so much that he would go confront this
guy who
ruined his life uh even further in civil
war
and was in prison and then break him out
of prison and this kind of
rushed uh last minute prison break
that felt like a lame uh ocean's eleven
thing it would have been a lot cooler if
we saw like the planning
and and just like if that would have
been a much more thought out
sequence right anything like i mean it
doesn't have to be
uh shawshank redemption or silence of
the lambs like two of the best cinematic
prison escapes that really kept you
guessing exactly how this is gonna go
out
um but like really you're just going
through the classic oh there's a prison
riot and i'm going to put on a prison
guard uniform
steal his badge and get out and just
like avoid cameras it
felt like a joke and it felt like kind
of disservice to the badass version of
zemo that we were presented in civil war
yeah
and like you know zemo is this super
smart guy so
it was as simple as all right create a
distraction so i can get out
i feel like you would have done that a
long time ago because it seems like a
very
it seemed very easy for zebo to just
escape he's just like all right put on a
costume and then now i'm out super quick
super quick hey look this is a tv show
we still enjoy most of what's going on
here i don't want to gripe too much
but in terms of what zemo's next step is
he seems to be a guy without a country
obviously he's going to betray sam and
bucky at some point
i just want to know what it's going to
be over um
mt before we were started rolling you
mentioned this idea that zemo would he
go
kill isaiah bradley as another yes
because zema was
not about super soldiers at all and with
isaiah's blood being a factor in
the creation of more super soldiers i
feel like zemo is just probably like
you know what let's just uh get that out
of the picture like because
this this is a factor that's still here
he's alive he's a it's a 90 year old
factor
let's just get rid of it i mean why not
i mean just so
so we just don't have any more super
soldiers so we can stop the power broker
from from we get rid of all of his vials
and then we get rid of isaiah
now there's no more problem well
depending on where steve is we don't
really know what happened to steve
but it's really sounding like in the in
this episode
that they keep using past tense with
with steve
and i'm just like is he really gone i
hope not
but yeah see i think i think zemo is
going to kill
john walker i i i think john walker
might go early
interesting because sam and bucky get
that shield back we've seen that in
all the promo footage and it's like
would he part with that shield
i don't think that shields a prop shield
i don't think there's multiple shields i
think there's just that one shield
and i think some mission where they all
end up in a snowy field together
uh based off of set photos where you
know the four of them are together
and it's snowy and based off of like
you know how uh if zemo like that would
be his ultimate revenge he actually gets
to kill the new captain america
uh i think that would be wild and i
think that would give us
uh a full arc for john walker as someone
who started sympathetic it would make us
feel a bit bad for john walker it's just
another government instrument who and
you know doesn't really get his own life
at the end of the day and uh
and that would make zemo part from these
two and they would get the shield back
you know or they could get the shield
back because somehow they're gonna have
to get it back and i just don't know how
john walker's gonna part ways with it
otherwise i i mean man that's a very
interesting if zemo does kill john
walker i will scream
audibly i will be like oh eric was right
just do that uh if i'm wrong or when i'm
wrong just say oh
what's wrong aaron was right still
um but no it was that would be crazy if
zemo kills walker because
they're setting up walker walker's
character to be like this really
like torn and this person struggling to
fill in
uh capped shoes so for him for them just
to be like all right
you struggled and you failed and now
you're dead that'd be some ball or
i would love that i would
it would be it would be crazy it would
be some some like game of thrones-ish
type stuff well
good era games of thrones well we do
have three more episodes of this uh
series left so time is running out but
i'm so excited to see what they do next
we're gonna leave it there for this
episode of inside marvel
our after show for the falcon winter
soldier i want to thank mt for diving
into this episode with me
hey thank you for you know being with me
as well because you are amazing it's a
gift it is a gift
uh empty and i are gonna be back next
friday for our reaction to
episode four and our after show we're
gonna answer all the questions you've
had about
it and make sure to follow mt at
mastertainment follow me at ea boss
follow me rock star subscribing inside
marvel wherever you get your podcast
thank you for watching
uh we're going to jump now to our stereo
listeners because we have the democrats
minister stereo we're going to take your
questions
so get ready stick around um but for now
we're going to close out with our
favorite moment of the episode which has
got to be
[Music]
you